what is going on YouTube ohhara here
today I want to talk about Zoro's past
before he met Luffy for that we will
take a closer look at the facts and dive
into his character is childhood and how
he came to be the very first straw hat
as always guys if you aren't familiar
with the one piece story be careful
because there will be spoilers ahead but
now without further ado let's get right
into it
so guys before we talk about his history
I want to talk a little bit about sorrow
as a person and as a character and for
that at first I want to share some
personal data of sorrows with you now
the first thing you would need to know
about sorrow is that his full name is
the pirate hunter roronoa zoro and he's
actually the only person in destroyed
crew who has been named after pirate
that existed in real life that pirate
and I think I'm gonna pronounce that
wrong was from say Lolo Mara
probably a French name I would assume
and I kind of slaughtered that I'm sorry
for that and he was actually known as
the cruelest of the Caribbean pirates so
from that name the Japanese
pronunciation became the law and that's
where Zorro got his name from dead
information we got from one of the first
s P SSE's where Oda himself actually
admitted to borrowing the name from real
life now the next thing we should look
at is Sorrows age and he's currently 21
after the time skip and that makes him
19 when he first meets Luffy his
birthday is actually the 11th of
November so if anyone plans on
celebrating it's gonna be very soon
regarding Zoro's height he's actually
fairly tall when we first get to know
him he's five foot ten and a half and
after the time skip he's five foot
eleven and a half so he grew a little
bit over to two years so for the
non-metric users under you that is 178
centimeters first and after the time
skip 180 and one centimeters so he's
definitely fairly tall maybe not four I
don't know Dutch standards but for
Japanese standards for sure he's a tall
dude now regarding his position in the
crew he is actually the swordsman of the
straw hat pirates and he's actually
possibly also the first made of Luffy
which is pretty much his right-hand man
now when we get a little bit more
personal we know that zeros favorite
food is actually white rice seeking meat
and yeah mostly ale that's what he's
drinking all the time and he actually
also likes pretty much anything that
goes well with a also his sleeping
rhythm is kind of weird he goes to sleep
at around 4 a.m. in the morning but gets
back up three hours later at 7 a
so he only gets a full three hours of
sleep every night which doesn't really
sound healthy but looking at how best to
do this it seems to work for him now
since these are all facts that he would
probably also find in a newspaper in the
one-piece world to better understand the
person sorrow let's take a look and get
a little bit deeper into his personality
and to just character so when we look at
sorrow himself and how he presents
himself to most other people he firstly
appears as a very stern serious and also
kind of distant kind of person he often
stands a little bit away from the group
doesn't participate in so many parties
isn't the guy who's joking around a lot
and also looks a little bit more
introverted another maybe a little bit
more negative quality is Saros losing
bloodlust and that's probably something
that's more noticeable to enemies of the
straw hats but sorrow definitely someone
who likes the thrill of a fight and who
also likes to see blood and he basically
wants to cut people so that's kind of
his thing and we've already seen this in
quite a few occasions that opposed to
Luffy surra really doesn't mind killing
people and we've seen him kill people
before and that doesn't mean that Luffy
doesn't kill people because we don't
want to know what happened to many of
the people that were kind of in the way
when Luffy went on the rampage but Luffy
doesn't fight with the intent to kill
while Zorro doesn't really mind if his
opponent dies or if he survives in the
sense now to fulfill your dream of
becoming the best swordsman in the world
you definitely need one thing over all
else and that is determination and that
definitely something that sort of
doesn't lag in the slightest
cuz once he sets his mind on something
he really pulls through and you can see
that him basically every aspect of his
life it doesn't matter if it's in his
intense training if it is in his fights
or if it's just in general how he
approaches any difficult situation in
his life he's just the kind of person
who once he's decided he wants to do
something goes through till the end
and those things also kind of play a
little bit into the fact that Sora is
the kind of person who tends to hide his
emotions a little bit from the outside
world and maybe even a little bit from
himself
the only thing or the only kind of
emotion that pops out of him here and
then is his anger towards an enemy port
maybe towards Angie and one of the
reasons for this might be that Sora
strongly believes that emotions kind of
hinder your judgement as a swordsman and
she kind of tries to stay calm stay
neutral to make the best judgments when
it's coming to a fight we actually see
him crying only twice on the whole story
once with queena and once after he was
defeated by mihawk and promises luffy to
become the greatest swordsman in the
world also not to paint a wrong picture
there of course are someone who smiles
and celebrates here and then and it's
not like we don't see sorrow happy or
being silly sometimes it's just his
general attitude or his general
personnel that's certainly not as open
not as celebrative as that of his
crewmates and that general approach kind
of mirrors whenever the crew is in a
situation of hardship or sadness caseros
me usually the one who stays calm who
has a solemn and stoic face and kind of
is the one who is still able to make the
right decision
and that already brings me to the next
point and that is the deep care that
sorrow feels for his comrades and the
fact that he does everything to protect
his friends and I think exactly that is
one of the things that make the
difference from sorrow just being the
dupe with the swords who's incredibly
strong and cool to actually creating a
really complex and interesting character
that we can actually also admire for
more than just strength but also for
empathy and also for a deep level of
friendship and respect and this can also
be found in Sorrows extremely strong
feeling for honor loyalty and also duty
and we can see that for example when
he's fighting against mihawk where he
would rather die and be stabbed in the
front than being shameful and turning
his back on me Hawk and his opponent
and we can also see it the moment Musab
wants to rejoin the crew when he
actually tells Luffy no you are the
captain you are our leader you can't
just take him back within disrespecting
you so it's those moments when you
really see how much those words honor
loyalty and Duty mean to zero and it's
really something that makes out a huge
part of his personality and standing
even more into contrast with his
bloodlust we have some moments with soar
away actually shows open kindness
towards others a good example for that
is when he carries the man who was shot
by Carlos into the hospital without
having any connections with him but also
for example when he protects the girl
that is the reason why he's tied up in
the first place and Luffy has to save
him and again here this place kind of
nicely into his next characteristic and
that is his recklessness
for example defying a world noble
defying the Marines often fighting
without any consideration of his health
or even his life he's definitely
together with Luffy of course one of
those people who don't think about
themselves but are there when it's going
down and all those things I just listed
together make an ultimate combination
for me and they are what makes ro such a
special character and such a lovable
character in the one-piece story because
the ultimate combination can be for
example very very good scene when sorrow
takes all of Luffy Spain at the end of
thriller bark and in that moment not
only is he prepared to take on all the
hardship his captain has gone through
he's actually prepared to end his dream
of becoming the best swordsman in the
world and prepared to die for his
captain and in my opinion that's kind of
a combination of the determination the
kindness the recklessness but also the
strong sense of honor loyalty and Duty
that are all part of his personality now
before we get into his history I quickly
wanted to note the small character
quirks that come with Sur as well and
that is for one the running gag that he
has a really bad sense of direction even
though he has such a sharp mind when it
comes to battling
and also of course his rivalry with
Sanji which is also really interesting
and I'm interested to see if that will
develop into something into the story
now let's get finally into Sara's
backstory and the first thing that I
would like to say is that it's very
likely that he was born in the East blue
since as we know it's very difficult to
cross oceans but of course as we know
from Sandy's example it's not impossible
so while we can't say for a hundred
percent that Xaro is from the East blue
it is still very likely since we already
saw him as a small kid there the next
thing is that we basically know nothing
of sorrows' parents or family or
siblings or anything and as far as we
know even sorrow doesn't know anything
about them it might be different of
course but he never mentioned anything
so the first traces we have of Star
Sorrows backstory is that he took down
several dojos before arriving at issuing
dojo and each in dojo is located in
Shenmue suki village that is actually
basically the translation for frost moon
village and this is located somewhere in
the east blue it is supposed to be
somewhere close to dawn island Luffy's
home place though since it's the town
that was visited by monkey dragon and
the revolutionaries after saving the
people from the great terminal to kind
of stock up on supplies and get more
treatment for the injured residents and
they were actually assisted by the dojo
for this now the reason that's are all
stuck with exactly this dojo is pretty
simple because even though when he came
he was able to defeat pretty much all of
the adults there he could not defeat
queena the daughter of the dojo master
cocido and for that reason he decided to
stay there and train and get stronger
with her over the years the two of them
actually had 2,000 fights and queena won
all of them so finally Saro decided to
challenge her to a fight with real
swords and when it came down to the
fight even though he had improved
incredibly since that first match he
still lost the fight and he actually
cried with frustration when it happened
and in that moment in emotions he told
Queen about his dream to become the
world's greatest swordsman and then
something unexpected happened because
Queen herself confined into sorrow that
they actually shared the same dream
but queena also told him that she knew
that she would never reach that dream
because she could never attain it and
she explains to Xaro that her father had
told her that girls basically could
never be true sword masters and that her
fighting potential was just gonna grow
weaker and weaker the more her body
matured into that of a woman and Xaro
emancipated as he is basically is super
annoyed with her attitude and explains
to her that one day he will be able to
beat her and not because she's a woman
but because he will be more skilled than
her and at that moment the two of them
make the promise that one of the two of
them is gonna be the world's best
swordsman one day the next morning after
their fight and after the big promise
sari comes into the dojo just to find
out that Queen actually had fallen down
the stairs while trying to get a
sharpening block and died and sorrow was
a really really great pain at that and
was really angry with her and accusing
her of running away from the promise
they made the previous night before and
finally by overcoming a little bit of
his pain Sarah asks Queen s father for
the honor of taking the Votto Jumanji
the sword and Queen aboard to take it
with him and he gets the permission and
with this sword Sora promises to fulfill
the dream the two of them had in her
stead as well and to become the greatest
swordsman for the sake of both of them
and what's interesting about that is
that there are a lot of theories that
queen is still alive and we'll see her
again wha know or that she's actually
the comet of smoker which actually has
been debunked since Oda has actually
drawn sushi Kia's as a child which
actually doesn't look like Queen at all
and in my opinion there would be no
point in Queen uh still being alive
since the point of her death being that
it was just so frustratingly meaningless
and in my opinion that is what really
makes out great character building
because it was a huge lesson that Sarah
had to learn that someone could actually
die or someone as honorable and someone
as skilled as Queen I could die not from
fighting as another strong swordsman or
being defeated by him or or someone else
in an honorable battle but actually die
by a stupid thing like falling down the
stairs and that is actually the tragic
thing Sora learns in that moment and in
my opinion is a great part of the
character building for him so I think
the way that Oda handled this is on the
one hand side frustratingly cruel and
frustratingly unnecessary but at the
same time also a very very great act of
writing and a very great part of who
Sarah became as a person so after
Karina's death sorrow kept training in
the gym for another few years honing his
skills becoming stronger and stronger
and eventually Sarah learned of the
existence of Dracul hawk-i mihawk who
actually currently holds the title of
the greatest swordsman in the world and
of course his goal being to become the
greatest swordsman in the world he would
have to defeat the current strongest
swordsman in the world so he set out to
sea to search for me Hawke in order to
challenge him to a duel however on his
journey he got lost and he couldn't find
his way back home to the dojo so in
order to survive on his own he took on
the job as a bounty hunter and hunted
pirates as a way of paying for his
living expenses and he fairly quickly
built up a big reputation for him as the
infamous pirate hunter roronoa zoro in
the east blue and even greater in the
grand line at one point he was actually
also known as the strongest swordsman in
the east blue and that's also around the
time when he met the two bounty hunters
Johnny and yosaku with whom he spent
some time in a group and because of his
great reputation also in the grand line
the baroque works that was led by
crocodile at that time started to offer
Zorro a position as one of the numbered
agents within the organization and Zorro
actually said that he would be willing
to
accept the offer under the condition
that he would be become the new leader
of the organization which obviously was
declined so he had to kill mr. seven out
of self-protection because they would
have killed him otherwise now as he kept
continuing his journey sorrow arrived at
one point in shells town where her
meppel the son of the corrupted marine
captain actually released his pet wolf
in town and it was chasing after a small
girl named Rika and Zara actually saved
her from the wolf and killed it so out
of revenge for his wolf howl Mapple told
sorrow that if he would agree to be tied
to a pole for 30 days without eating
anything he would grant him amnesty
which were basically not make him a
criminal out of the Marines I of course
he was tricking Zorro but he believed
him and agreed to do that so on the 9th
day of sorrow being restrained to the
pole in the quartet of the Marine base
Kobe and Luffy arrived in the town and
of course
Kobe wants to join the Marines Luffy
already wants to invite zero to become
his new crew member and they arrived
where zero is bound just in time to
witness the small girl feeding him some
of the rice balls Zara actually tho
declines and tells the girl she should
go away basically trying to protect her
and hoping she doesn't get seen and
punished for it of course at that point
helmeppo enters and sees the food stumps
on it says it's not salted enough and
after they leave Luffy asks ro to join
his crew who of course says he will
never become a pirate and Luffy doesn't
give up though he feeds him the dirtied
rice balls and zero tells Rika that they
tasted delicious and that's also again
something where his kindness is actually
really shining there later on Rika
actually explains the circumstances
under which taro has become a prisoner
of the Marines - Luffy which kind of
enrages him and makes his decision to
make him his first crewmember even more
file and when her meppel said that he
would execute sorrow Luffy is pretty
pissed and starts punching him in the
face
under which our Mapple hurries back to
his father to seek revenge for the punch
so now that he knows that
Zorro will be executed he sets out to
the Marine base to look for Zorro sorts
and hope to convince him by that to join
his crew and she actually crushes the
nubile statue of Captain Morgan and
forces helm Apple to show him the swords
which he then takes and wants to go back
to Zorro who is having the situation
explained by Coby who's trying to untie
him Luffy just arrives in time to save
them from an execution or firing squad
by just standing in front of them and he
actually saves Sora and Colby by that
and Sora accepts to join Lucy's crew in
that situation after being freed he
actually demonstrates his unique
fighting style his son Tori U is three
sword style and he also shares his
ambition of becoming the best swordsman
in the world after defeating the Marines
Luffy and Zorro actually tend to leave
the island and Coby kind of like wants
to take his chance to become a Marine
so Luffy kindly enough stages a kind of
brawl with him and as a result of that
he's actually allowed to be a recruit in
the Marines and the Marines actually
turned a blind eye on him and Xaro
because they were kind of tyrannized by
Morgan and were just happy to be free of
him which is also again one of the nice
things that aura does is he kind of has
those gray areas when it comes to
parties like it's easy to see the
Pirates as good and the Marines as bad
or the other way around but he does a
really good job of showing both sides of
the metal basically and with that Luffy
and Zorro set off for the next islands
and the next destination now before I go
I quickly want to address some of the
rumors that sorrows past is actually
kind of tied to one okuni where
destroyers are at the moment located and
if you follow one piece more or less
regularly you will probably have
stumbled upon some theories that connect
sora to water in some way obviously it
is believed that since Sora is a
swordsman and Juan o is the country of
samurai there must be some connection
there also some people
Soraa has family from guano or is from
guano himself and just moved from there
to the east blue when he was a child
maybe getting lost another argument that
you hear here and then is that there's a
strong connection between Zoro and ryu
ma the samurai he fought on Thrilla Park
or actually more in the body of the
samurai and many assume that he might be
an ancestor of sorrow for the simple
reason that not only do they look alike
when you look at the early drawings of
Rima that are actually cannon that he
made before drawing one piece but also
sorrow having his sword and both of them
executing dragons so some people think
that since the sword is considered a
treasure of one okuni they think Rima
only allowed sorrow to take the sword
because he's a rightful heir of the
sword but then again of course it was
only rumors body and he was possessed by
Brookes shadow so even though there are
some similarities there I don't know if
that's plausible proof that there's a
connection between the two characters
another theory takes a little different
approach and it actually states that
sorrow sense a cushy dough is actually a
citizen of one oh and that will meet him
again sometime in the story and I think
actually that's a very likely
possibility it's actually more likely
than sorrow himself being from wanna in
my opinion because it would just kind of
be what we had with Sandy in the whole
cake island arc a little bit recycled so
even though there's the possibility that
there's some relationship to Zorro I
would be surprised not disappointed but
surprised if oda kind of did the whole
here learn about the secret roots of
sorrow and wanna thing again but I
wouldn't complain of course but I think
what we can all agree on is that whether
he has ties to one okuni or not we will
definitely find out more about the past
of sorrow in the future thank you so
much for listening guys if you actually
made it to this point in the video I'm
really appreciative that you guys keep
up with me noting about one piece and as
always guys I'm curious to what you
think about the topic so leave a comment
below
share your opinion if you liked the
video leave me a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe if you want to be
notified for my new content I will see
you guys next time and until then have a
great week
[Music]